[Music]
the annals of ancient egyptian king
thutmosa iii described a marvelous
foreign bird that gives birth daily
zoroastrians viewed them
as spirits whose cries told of the
cosmic struggle
between darkness and light romans
brought them on their military campaigns
to foretell the success of future
battles
and today this bird still occupies an
important
though much less honorable position on
our dinner plates
the modern chicken is descended
primarily from the red
jungle fowl and partially from three
other closely related species
all native to india and southeast asia
the region's bamboo plants produce
massive amounts of fruit just once every
few decades
jungle fowl's ability to lay eggs daily
may have evolved to take advantage of
these rare feasts
increasing their population when food
was abundant
this was something humans could exploit
on a consistent basis
and the birds weak flight capabilities
and limited need for space
made them easy to capture and contain
the earliest domesticated chickens
dating at least back to 7000 years ago
weren't bred for food but for something
considered less savory today
the aggressiveness of breeding males
armed with natural leg spurs
made cockfighting a popular
entertainment
by the second millennium bce chickens
had spread from the indus valley
to china and the middle east to occupy
royal menageries
and to be used in religious rituals but
it was in egypt where the next chapter
in the bird's history began
when a hen naturally incubates eggs she
will stop
laying new ones and sit on a clutch of
six or more eggs
for 21 days by the middle of the first
millennium bce
the egyptians had learned to
artificially incubate chicken eggs
by placing them in baskets over hot
ashes
that freed up hens to continue laying
daily
and what had been a royal delicacy or
religious offering
became a common meal around the same
time as egyptians were incubating eggs
phoenician merchants introduced chickens
to europe where they quickly became an
essential part of european livestock
however for a long time the chicken's
revered status continued to exist
alongside its culinary one the ancient
greeks used fighting roosters
as inspirational examples for young
soldiers
the romans consulted chickens as oracles
and as late as the 7th century
the chicken was considered a symbol for
christianity
over the next few centuries chickens
accompanied humans wherever they went
spreading throughout the world through
trade conquest
and colonization after the opium wars
chinese breeds were brought to england
and crossed with local chickens
this gave rise to a phenomenon called
hen fever
or the fancy with farmers all over
europe
striving to breed new varieties with
particular combinations of traits
this trend also caught the attention of
a certain charles darwin
who wondered if a similar selective
breeding process
occurred in nature darwin would observe
hundreds of chickens while finalizing
his historic work
introducing the theory of evolution
but the chicken's greatest contribution
to science was yet to come
in the early 20th century a trio of
british scientists conducted
extensive cross-breeding of chickens
building on gregor mendel's studies of
genetic inheritance
with their high genetic diversity many
distinct traits
and only seven months between
generations chickens were the perfect
subject
this work resulted in the famous punnett
square
used to show the genotypes that would
result from breeding
a given pairing since then numerous
breeding initiatives have made chickens
bigger and meatier
and allowed them to lay more eggs than
ever meanwhile
chicken production has shifted to an
industrial factory-like model
with birds raised in spaces with a
footprint no larger than a sheet of
paper
and while there's been a shift towards
free-range farming due to animal rights
and environmental concerns
most of the world's more than 22 billion
chickens today
are factory farmed from gladiators and
gifts to the gods
to traveling companions and research
subjects chickens have played
many roles over the centuries and though
they may not have come before the
proverbial egg
chicken's fascinating history tells us a
great deal
about our own
so what about the chickens what do they
think of all this
since we can't say for sure why not take
a moment to learn more about how animals
communicate
and how they experience pain